hunger eagle
uh father gascoigne
having a norwegian norwegian flag all
right whoever is guys
hopefully he's good
and he finally beats me
so my old
but not gold
old but not gold
okay this is a very careless move now
he's
yeah he needs to do something about
bishop h6 and he does this
okay i wonder if bishop g5 wins
miss something
likely no but okay this is just a banter
please so why not to do well i need to
go for bishop g5 oh he doesn't know what
to take
that's how he refutes me that's that's
kind of brilliant that's kind of
brilliant
all right
so if he's
such a
strong player
what should i do
okay i think first of all first and
foremost i should castle
it doesn't matter doesn't matter what's
going on i should castle first
so probably i'm close to my one and only
fiasco yeah 95 is a good one indeed
so what do i do now
maybe just go for king b1 yeah so we
don't count all the pieces here so we
just
we just go for it
we play we fight we lose
at first we play king d1
firstly play king d1 i i don't want to
look particularly stupid just being
stupid
is enough for me actually
i'll take it to the queen probably
okay i'm just open
for losing a piece for opening a file
it doesn't really matter
father gets clean
maybe it's goose coin no it's it's a
coin for goose greedy goose greedy goose
is going out of course greedy goose is
tanking my
piece
uh because okay that's that's that's
just part of his nature being greedy
goose
well uh okay please a piece up is uh i
think and that should be enough to beat
me
so i have no idea i just double my rooks
onto each file
and pray
and now he runs
that's interesting
that's so interesting let's play g3
i mean of course like don't do this at
home this is complete nonsense
but
it should be it will
are you scared my friend
i think yes you are
i think yes you are but this is not
enough to be scared
this is
alice's is not enough to lose the game
then you're basically a piece up for
nothing
okay who cares let's say 94
and let's just go for it
okay let's go f4
so all his pieces are bad but he has an
extra one
so that's why he's winning
for sure
what should i do right now okay maybe 93
knight g5
and then i flack him in the end
now but he even has like a half a minute
more than me
alice
alice
i thought i lost now i rest
okay
hopefully he's not
going those bottles on time
okay let's give a check
i don't know what now
should i i think i should collect
something i should collect a rook at
least
or not
or i shouldn't
let's kinda kinda strange
i guess lyrical five first
i don't know i
feel like i might have i might
i'm maybe i'm going to find a chance
here to
complex things for him
make things more complex but if nothing
no
oh he's running
no man stay
please stay
do not run away
okay we'll do it okay let's take
let's take
let's retreat okay now it goes into the
flanking mode
i can see i'm particularly good at this
but i don't think i'm worse than this
guy
no clue
okay we trade rooks
oops
a juicy and a fruitful pawn
a very fruitful poem
yeah
yeah deserved deserved
dessert victory
yeah
come on